foreign
let's go to Denver Colorado and talk to
Dear Marie what's up Marie
hi Dr John how are you partying um
that's not true yeah yeah
what's up
um so
I lost my husband about a year ago and
oh God hold on hold on hold on what
happened
uh PTSD
he died by Suicide
yeah
ah God I'm so sorry Marie
thank you
um hold on take a breath take a breath
take a breath take a breath take a big
big deep breath
don't blow by it I'm sorry
thank you
uh shortly after I lost him
um
my best friend and her family were in a
severe car accident and it looked like
they weren't going to survive
and
their whole family survived and they're
all relatively back to normal life right
now
um
and I find myself
really angry and jealous
that
their family is intact and mine is not
and how do I move forward with that
friendship
um am I a monster for having me feelings
it's a lot
to answer the the question underneath
the question underneath the question
here you're not crazy
you're not a monster
no
your anger and your jealousy and your
frustration
and
heartbreak that's all good and right
or to be a nerd about it it's totally
normal
I'm sorry
thank you how do I move forward
you're like okay that was cute what do I
do now
sorry
what was what was your husband's name
Neil tell me about him
um he was a veteran
and
probably the smartest guy I've ever met
in my life
um
he was really
an amazing husband and father and
he was somebody that we always joked
with everybody's buddy he never
ever met an enemy
and he was carrying around a suitcase
full of full of Darkness huh
did he leave you a note
he did
not say much didn't say much
oh
um just that
he was sorry and that he he loved me and
trusted me to do what was best for our
kids
and uh
that he hoped we would see each other
again someday
you know that's not your fault Marie
right
foreign
I know that you've spent every day of
the last year asking yourself what if I
just said this what if I had done this
what if I hadn't done that
so hear me say this one's not on you
he's damn lucky to have you in his life
thanks
so the path out
is the path I was just I was just trying
to to mirror for you okay or just trying
to give you a picture of what it looks
like
and it's flow and it's short and it's
awful
something you have to practice okay and
the reason I'm telling you that is I
don't lie to you because I don't want to
get off the phone and you think balloons
are going to fall from the sky because
that's not how it works
sure okay what's gonna happen is my one
of my greatest friends in the world his
name is Trevor and Trevor
um was working at a print shop and he
tore his bicep he's a big muscle head
he's like the hottest guy in the world
and he was Beefcake and he tore his
bicep and it rolled up on his shoulder
and he got it surgically repaired and he
had to do all of this PT work all this
uh physical therapy
and he said it was brutal and it was
hard and it hurt all the time and then
after a while he ran out of PT because
his insurance quit paying so he just
went back to his regular life and he
kind of favored it and favored it and
favored it and one day a box fell off
at the print shop and he reached up and
grabbed the Box just just reflexively
and he remembers going huh that didn't
hurt like that's he was well
and so that's what's gonna happen
if you'll do these things I'm gonna tell
you what's going to happen is you're
going to just have an experience in six
or nine months
when you are going to be overwhelmed
with gratitude and laughter and joy
and it will hit you on the way home
oh wait a minute
you see what I'm saying
yeah that's how it's going to happen
there's not going to be glitter or
anything falling from the ceiling okay
you spent the last year in a black hole
and if I'm being really truthful with
you you're going to be there probably
for a little bit longer okay
it's hard yeah you got little ones too
yeah
um
my oldest is two and a half and he died
when I was three months pregnant and so
the baby is five months
boys or girls
so this will be hard for a long long
time okay
as part of your
part of the story that's going to be
your life is letting these little girls
know that Daddy was sick and that he
loved them more than life itself you got
a note that proves it
yeah okay
so number one you've got to know you're
not nuts you're not crazy when you get
mad when you get angry and when you see
a dad holding his daughter holding his
other daughter's hand walking in the
mall and you just want to go punch him
in the mouth that feeling is right it's
okay
you're not crazy
don't go hit him because then you'll go
to jail but I want you to not be like oh
my gosh what's wrong with me I'm the
worst I can't no go yeah yeah that sucks
and then you've spent the last year
really pissed off
that he left you hanging right
yeah
that that anger is right too
but when you're able to I want you to
begin to also plus the anger not the
anger goes away plus the anger
remember how
he lit up a room
and remember the joy he brought to other
people
and remember how he made you feel when
you were down that one time
what we're doing is we are slowly but
surely turning our dial
to one of
Darkness to one of light it's one of
gratitude to use a word that has been
beaten to death in the Instagram world
and what we're going to do with your
friend is it's literally practicing
we're gonna practice honoring that
family
practice by writing him a letter about
how happy you are for them and never
give it to them just practice writing
that
and say the words in that letter because
no one's ever going to read it I'm so
freaking pissed off that
my life like my family got busted up
and yours gets to remain whole
I'm so grateful y'all are whole
see what I'm saying all we're doing is
practicing when you're around them
and you feel sorrow and you feel your
chest get tight
that's all okay but I want you to
practice feeling it not just getting so
righteously indignant and angry that you
wallpaper over it
okay
You're Gonna Miss Neil for a long long
time
and that's ultimately what that anger is
so I miss my guy
like my forever guy miss him
yeah
right
yeah I you're absolutely right
you also need to find a friend or two
that you can say these things out loud
to because you can't do this by yourself
grief Demands a witness
so you're gonna have to find one or two
women that you can text that you really
trust with your soul
or that you can call and say I'm going
to visit so and so and her stupid
freaking perfect husband with still has
all his hair and didn't cover himself up
in tattoos and doesn't have a jacked up
Jeep out in the he's gonna be there too
and then he'd be able to go boo with you
on your side right
yeah and then you can walk in and your
chest is going to get tight and you're
going to see this guy he's gonna smile
and say Welcome to our house and your
friend's gonna be your girlfriend's
gonna be there and your daughters are
going to run in the house and you're
going to feel it for a second
damn it Neil you should be here too
[Music]
and then we're gonna walk in and we're
gonna smile and we're gonna choose
gratitude
not choose faking we're going to choose
gratitude look how beautiful this house
is look how beautiful this marriage is
and what you'll find is if you commit to
practicing this over time in addition to
feeling your anger feeling so mad
and by the way this anger will come in
waves this grief comes in waves it's
going to be four years old when your
daughter hears something from somebody
at school and comes home
and wants to have another conversation
about her daddy
God you're gonna get pissed again that
you have to have this conversation you
gotta tell her you know you know what I
mean this is going to be part of your
story
those are all okay they're all okay
hmm
if nothing else you hear me say you're
not screwed up you're not messed up
you're not irredeemable you're not a
monster
you're a mom who loves her two baby
girls and you're a wife who is
heartbroken because you lost your
Forever guy
have you written him a letter yet
I told him you hate him
well is writing a letter you gotta do
that
I always tell people to write three
letters
you gotta tell them to write in the
letter
about
how mad you are upset you are how
frustrated and angry you are
you gotta write him a letter that tells
him how sad you are
then you got to write him a letter that
it's going to let him know who you're
going to become in the coming years
what he's gonna miss
because Marie is going to be the best
single mom the world has ever seen
and she's going to make many of this
madness
and you're going to
not forget the the forget the name Neil
because Neil Neil was all right Neil was
just sick
yeah but those three letters are
important because it takes what's in
that in your body and puts it out into
the ether
it also gives your body permission to be
angry and really sad and optimistic all
at the same time
will you commit to that
I will yeah
and then the fourth letter is that
pretend the letter God help you don't
send it please don't send it to your
friends
we're good friends but I don't know that
we're that good
I hey
I have an un as my wife says uh
I'm awkward in what conversations I will
just have at the dinner table with our
friends because I thought every friend
group did that but evidently they do not
but I even would be weirded out if
someone's like man
I really just being around you really
um pisses me off and makes me mad like I
would be like I don't know what to do
um so yeah maybe a counselor but you
might be a good person or some other
friends but
um
what we're gonna do over the next one to
two to five to six to ten years is
slowly turn that dial from one of black
hole to one of gratitude
and when you see a whole family it
becomes something that you quietly pump
your fist and you say hell yeah
when you see a broken family or a family
experiencing loss it's you're going to
beeline to them because you're gonna
have been there and you're gonna be able
to look somebody in the eye and put your
hand on both sides of their face and say
I know you call me anytime
but that's not for now right now it's
still here no that's for healing right
now
so start with writing um Neil letters
all three of them
and listen to me I'll be with you all
through this you holler anytime I can
help walk alongside me I mean I'm
walking alongside you any way I can help
and I want you to hang on the line I'm
going to send you a copy of on your past
change your future
um just it's a measly gift I can give to
you it's all I got
um actually I'm gonna send you the
parents and kids cars it'll be something
fun for you and your daughters to play
with it's the questions even though I
guess you told me they're really really
young so you may put them in a drawer
for a few years
um but I want you to read on your past
change your future as
just here we are
this is what grief feels like this is
what grief looks like and then what are
we gonna do next
I'm so grateful for you I'm heartbroken
with you
we're all heartbroken with you Marie
and we'll be with you with next steps
thank you so much for being brave thank
you for the call